♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
After marrying
his cousin,
giving a press conference
at a landscaping company,
and almost masturbating
in the "Borat" movie,
Rudy Giuliani
has finally slipped up.
That's right.
A jury in Washington, D.C.,
last week ordered Rudy Giuliani
to pay nearly $150 million
in the defamation case
brought against him
by two Georgia election workers.
Okay, but he for sure
doesn't have that much money.
You might as well order a dog
to drive you to the airport.
A lot of stress for the dog,
but you're not getting
to the airport.
Russian President Vladimir Putin
was formally nominated
over the weekend
to run in the 2024 presidential
election.
Said Putin,
"If anyone has any questions,
my window is always open.
He's prone to defenestration.
In a new interview, presidential
hopeful Robert F. Kennedy Jr.
says that he thinks people
should be able
to debate the legitimacy
of the election
without being dismissed
as crazy.
Oh, buddy, that's not why
people think you're crazy.
You can debate the election.
What you can't do
is work out in blue jeans.
A Senate staffer was fired
over the weekend
for allegedly filming a sex tape
inside a committee hearing room.
It's the first time
anyone in that room
has ever come together.
Former UN ambassador Nikki Haley
criticized former president
Trump in a new interview
and said that he had
the opportunity
to stop the Capitol attack,
and before that,
he had an opportunity not to
start it.
According to the latest data
released from Pornhub,
the search term "granny"
increased in popularity by 132%
because what better
to hear after
"Who's your Daddy?"
than "I can't remember."
Same dude wrote that
as that "come together" joke.
We should check
his search history.
Or not.
Yeah. Or not.
Officials in New Mexico
have begun testing wastewater
at some high schools
for illicit drugs,
and found that most schools
tested positive for cocaine.
And it has to be
the students,
because there's no way
a teacher can afford cocaine.
Today it was Rolling Stones
guitarist Keith Richards'
80th birthday.
Even crazier, he celebrated by
going to lunch with his parents.
And finally, two seemingly
drunk men in Australia
were arrested after they climbed
into a construction site,
threw bags of concrete off
the scaffolding, fell asleep,
and then refused
to get down for eight hours.
Officials first suspected
they were drunk
when they were Australian.
President Biden reportedly
told aides in a recent meeting
that they need
to make progress
in reversing his decline
in poll numbers.
And hopefully, Jill
and Travis will understand.
According to a new report,
President Biden frequently
tells aides and friends
in private conversations
that he feels, quote,
so much younger than his age,
and I'm sure he does.
But it doesn't inspire
a ton of confidence
when you walk around
saying, "Man, I feel 73."
According to a new report,
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
is trying to improve
President Biden's diet,
or at least trying to get him
to add another food group.
The two Georgia
election workers
who won a $148 million verdict
on Friday against Rudy Giuliani
filed another lawsuit yesterday
after Giuliani
continued making false
statements about them.
Only Rudy could lose
a $148 million lawsuit
and say, "All right,
double or nothing!"
"Put it all on blue."
A new poll found that
3 in 10 people who voted
for former President Trump
want a president
who is willing to break rules
and laws,
and, in an act of desperation,
Biden ripped the tags
off his mattress.
According to a new poll,
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
has an approval rating
of just 6%.
Incidentally, 6% is also
what he's buffering at.
In a new campaign ad,
Republican presidential
hopeful Nikki Haley
says that President Biden
is too old
and calls for term limits
and mental competency tests,
which is why we need young,
sharp politicians
like New York Mayor Eric Adams.
-When you look at the totality
of the year,
if you had to describe it,
and it's tough to do
in one word,
what would that word be,
and tell me why?
-New York.
This is a place
where every day you wake up,
you could experience
everything from a plane
crashing into our trade center
to a person
who's celebrating
a new business that's open.
This is a very,
very complicated city,
and that's why it's
the greatest city on the globe.
-Honey! I don't want to go
to New York anymore.
Nikki Haley is right --
term limits might be
a good idea.
How about half a term?
Is that too soon?
Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
over the weekend
met Jacob Chansley,
the so-called
QAnon Shaman,
in what is being called
Hallmark's worst Christmas movie
ever.
The Greek yogurt company Chobani
has acquired the coffee chain
La Colombe for $900 million
because they are dedicated
to making sure
their customers
never leave the bathroom.
And finally,
a man in Alabama
who was arrested recently
for alleged possession
of a controlled substance
had a parrot on his shoulder
and told officers he was high
on mushrooms.
Said the parrot,
"Don't forget the crack."
Not good.
In rehearsal I nailed --
Oh, the parrot
was good earlier.
I shouldn't have burned it when
we were doing cards earlier.
"Don't forget --"
No, I still don't have it.
♪♪
The Colorado Supreme Court
ruled yesterday
that former President Trump
is ineligible
to run again
for president,
while the Florida Supreme Court
ruled he already won.
Supreme Court Chief Justice
John Roberts spoke yesterday
at the memorial service
for Justice Sandra Day O'Connor
and said, quote,
"She was so successful
that the barriers she broke down
are almost unthinkable today,"
adding,
"But we're working on it."
At a rally last night in Iowa,
former President Trump
told the crowd that immigrants
are, quote, destroying
the blood of our country.
Pretty ironic thing
to say in a state
that only exists
to produce corn syrup.
After facing comparisons
to Adolf Hitler,
former President Trump
said yesterday
that immigrants are destroying
the blood of our country
and added, quote, "They said,
oh, Hitler said that
in a much different way."
But you've already lost
the argument if you have to say,
"Guys, I wasn't quoting Hitler.
I was paraphrasing him."
That's right. After facing
comparisons to Adolf Hitler,
Trump said that immigrants
are destroying the blood
of our country
and added, quote,
"I've never read Mein Kampf,"
yet no one thought you had.
I'd be surprised if you read
The Art of the Deal.
At a conservative conference
yesterday,
Republican Senator Ted Cruz
told the crowd
that the left is unhappy
and added, quote,
"If you were a liberal woman
and you had to sleep with those
weenies, you'd be pissed too."
Well, joke's on you, Ted,
because liberal women
sleep with each other.
Dude.
The scooter rental company Bird
has filed for bankruptcy.
Apparently, it's not profitable
to charge people
ten bucks to chuck
your scooters into the river.
A 90-year-old woman
recently graduated
from
the University of North Texas
with a master's degree.
At least I hope
that's what they meant
when they said she passed.
Minnesota yesterday
unveiled its new state flag,
which features
a light blue background
with a white North Star.
The flag was designed
by Minnesota artist Lucas.
Good Lucas.
A new Jersey
police officer
was arrested yesterday
for allegedly
stealing drugs
from an evidence room.
Police confiscated the drugs,
but he's pretty sure
he knows how to get them back.
Finally, the CDC estimated
this week
that roughly 20% of
recent coronavirus infections
have been caused by
the newly-discovered subvariant,
JN.1, or as most Americans
are calling it,
allergies.
President Biden is reportedly
considering raising tariffs
on some Chinese goods.
Biden came up with the idea
the moment he realized
his fingers were stuck.
[ Laughter ]
Well, it's our last show
of the year,
so let's take a minute
to look back
on all the best moments
of 2023.
-Rudy Giuliani
to pay $148 million.
-Rudy Giuliani, $148 million.
-$148 million.
$148 million.
-What a year.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis yesterday
criticized the biblical city
of Bethlehem
and said it was
a "pigsty and disgrace."
Even worse,
he did it while caroling.
[ Laughter ]
A federal judge ruled yesterday
that the two Georgia
election workers who won
a $148 million defamation
judgment against Rudy Giuliani
may expedite their payout
because they have good cause
that Giuliani might try
to avoid paying them.
How did they come
to that conclusion?
Did they look
at any picture of him?
He definitely looks like a guy
who carries a quarter
on a string
so he can use payphones
for free.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Georgia
are looking for a woman
who allegedly posed
as a Waffle House employee,
worked at the restaurant
for two hours,
and then stole cash
from the register.
A spokesman for Waffle House
is calling her
employee of the month.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
Tesla drivers have
the highest accident rate.
In fact, one of them
accidentally crashed
an entire social media site.
[ Laughter ]
The FAA said that it expects
holiday air travel
will peak today.
Okay, but what
do they mean "expect"?
We all bought our tickets
a long time ago.
You could just check.
Is anybody showing up
to the airport
on December 21st on a whim?
"Yeah, you know,
I just came out here
to have dinner at Chili's,
and then, you know,
I thought, hell, maybe I'll fly
to Orlando, you know?
Everybody else
seems to be doing it."
[ Laughter ]
A city in California held
a contest to name its snow plow,
and the winning name
was "The Big Leplowski."
As opposed to Boston,
who went with
"I Plowed Ya Mutha."
[ Laughter and applause ]
CNN published a list this week
of the worst-behaved tourists
of 2023,
but I don't even need to read it
to know what was number one,
because I'm living it
every single day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
People work here!
People of business
are doing business!
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the billionaire
heir
to the luxury goods company
Hermès
has reportedly filed
to legally adopt
his middle-aged gardener
and leave him half
of his $13 billion fortune.
And I think we actually have
a photo of the gardener.
George!
-That was a monologue,
everybody,
we're up and running.
♪♪